the most depressing fan theory out there  involving the office revolves around  stanley  i'm going to die  the theory suggests that stanley  actually died in a fifth season episode  while michael tried resuscitating him  after dwight's ridiculous fire safety  drill since stanley hated work more than  anything the theory goes on to say that  he moved on to the afterlife with the  office as his own personal hell the  theory while odd echoes a sentiment many  fans have regarding season five's midway  point it's where they say the characters  became more cartoonish versions of  themselves according to the theory the  exaggerated qualities of the characters  after the fire drill has to do with how  stanley now perceives things since he's  on the other side is this plausible  absolutely not is this theory riddled  with plot holes sure but no matter how  silly it might seem this stanley theory  is definitely a fun one to analyze on  your next season 5 re-watch